the fear is dictating the day and of
course
like everybody else and i'm sure you did
as well i listened to joe rogan's
podcast with
dr robert malone the other day where he
summarized the the thing that i i mean i
used to call it stockholm syndrome but
mass formation psychosis is actually a
better way of looking at it injecting
fear into society
and allowing people in numbers to run
around and
you know whale flail their arms around
like everyone's going to die is a very
sure-fire way to
i suppose erase the concepts of you know
science and rational thought and liberty
and freedom and democracy
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am dr brett weinstein and i
have the honor of sitting today with
senator alex antic from south australia
senator welcome to dark horse thanks
brett great to be here and thanks for
having me
um there are a number of purposes that
we might have in the podcast today but i
think my primary one is this
as a citizen of the west somebody who
follows social patterns and politics
i have always thought that i understood
australia as a kind of fellow traveler
of the united states a similar
place with decidedly different mammals
i am less and less convinced that i
understand australia on the basis
that i see things coming across
media social and otherwise that suggests
a kind of
draconian shift in the australian
landscape
and at the same time
although i think i can interpret what
i'm seeing and i understand it to be
quite frightening i'm told by people in
australia that i've misunderstood the
evidence that in fact things are quite
normal and that i am
falling prey to a distortion
so i was hoping that you could help
me and my listeners understand what is
going on in australia relative to covet
19.
yeah look brett it's a it's a really
good question and there's a lot to
unpack out of all of that of course but
i've been saying to people for
the last few months the last few years
years even in australia um that if you
look outside the window in australia at
the moment you largely see the country i
think that we had and we have got and
i'm going to say it and and your
listeners won't like it the greatest
country in the world here and
but it is true we have a lot in common
with the united states and we have a lot
of things that are that are terrific
about this country lifestyle
you know system of government natural
resources beaches you name it friendly
people all the rest of it um so if you
look out the window at the moment in
australia you still see that
but the difficulty is that what's going
on
in that subtle space
of politics and of public discourse and
of course in our parliaments as well
gives me very very much
the reason for alarm and i'll explain
why um
as it stands we're still very similar
the united states and australia have a
similar but different path as we know
one of the great differences i think
though for australia is that
we were formed in around about the year
that you were fighting the
american war of independence
we were found the first fleet turned up
in 1788 in australia it was set up as a
penal colony the british
used it effectively as a way of parking
about 160 000
convicts who were brought out here for
the
heinous crimes of stealing loaves of
bread but our history is not forged in
war and fighting for our freedom like
the united states is and
my view is we're seeing the fruit of
that now the united states
fought against the british and fought
for for its freedom and i think
indelibly that's been marked in your
founding documents the bill of rights
the declaration of independence and and
all the things that go with it here we
almost and i've heard it said by learned
commentators that it's been said that
australia was a penal colony and has now
come back to being a penal colony i
think that's probably a bridge too far
but certainly we were always a country
that
lived under the specter of of
the police i think effectively i mean
that's how australia was born a lot of
free settlers and certainly south
australia here where i am was a free
colony set up by private enterprise but
ultimately australia's dna is one almost
of being more compliant and less
libertarian i think than the united
states and i think that's where the fork
in the road has gone um so as i said as
you look out the window it all looks
normal but what we're seeing in terms of
these protests particularly coming out
of places like victoria
which is one of our one of our states in
the country here down in the south
eastern part of the country it's a very
artistic city a very erudite city
and it's a city that has long had its
tradition for academic thought and all
the rest of it and at the moment it's
the city where all of the images of
strike breaking tactics of police
cracking down on protesters
and a lot of the really really hardcore
stuff it's the city in the world that
has had the longest run of lockdowns
this has had 260 days of lockdowns in
the last period
now that means people locked in their
homes so it's i guess to answer your
question it's a bit of a
mixed message there the the things that
are happening in australia are very real
the things that are happening even if
they're happening once are very
concerning and very frightening there's
a whole host of them by the way and
we'll discuss a few of them today i
suppose but certainly um
you know the australia the liberal
democracy that is australia is alive and
well but we have to make sure i think
here in this country people like myself
and other politicians that feel strongly
about this that we keep talking about
the chipping away at the edges of the
fabric of this nation because it's very
real it's very alarming
well i i think we've been through a
number of rounds of trying to assess
what we're seeing in the world social
media and regular media has a way of
putting the most alarming things on a
screen and the challenge always comes
back and says you're being misled
because you're seeing you know where the
protest is happening where the crackdown
is happening you're not seeing all of
the normalcy on the other hand
this bias exists
throughout history right even during
wartime most places at most times there
aren't shots being fired and so we can't
reassure ourselves too much the fact is
the agreement that we have in the west
with each other
is based on the idea that
rights are paramount and that they can
only be
abridged when a very high bar has been
met by government and i think many of us
myself included believe that the bar has
not been met in this case
and uh you know you joke about uh
australia being found as a penal colony
and some people suggesting that maybe
you've returned there and
on the one hand i get that maybe that's
a bit of an exaggeration on the other
hand i know that today i was looking at
yet another
video of michael gunner who i guess is
in your northern territory is that
correct that's correct and he was
declaring that uh
for
the unvaccinated only the number of
reasons that you are allowed to leave
your house is now down from five to
three you're not allowed to go more than
30 kilometers from your house
and this strikes me as both punitive and
i would say uh it is all but obvious
that it is punitive it is a punishment
designed to force people towards
vaccination and it is also extremely
restrictive of liberty so
not exactly a penal colony but uh the
analogy is not that great a stretch
yeah and look
you're quite right that's a relatively
recent um development i think in
australia but it's consistent with a
whole host of smaller ones that have
followed a similar line and they all
center around this issue about
segregation this development of a
two-tier society of people who are
vaccinated and people who are not and it
should be said that 90 of australians
are a little bit more now have have
taken that offer up have uh have taken
the vaccines up so we're we're a highly
vaccinated nation we're also told by
so-called expert modeling and i and i
one of the things i want to see in 2022
is the use of data modeling and the
phrase data modeling less because it's
it's you know it's always
um you know met with conjecture in this
case is true
um but we would we were told we would
the country would get back to normal at
80 percent well we're up to 90 now and
we're seeing instances like this in the
northern territory i mean this is
outrageous behavior out there and
michael gunner is um i think he's a
member of the labor party he's a
chief minister from the labour party
which is a
left-wing major party
and he has made a couple of
announcements over the course of the
last six months in particular the first
one was the statement that
words to the effect of i don't care if
uh you say you're not anti-vaxxed but if
you are against vaccine mandates then
you're an anti-vaxxer you know so using
that pejorative language in order to
marginalize
and then yesterday's announcement which
is as you described it a an announcement
whereby
the northern territory is is effectively
reinforcing that two-tiered society it's
saying we're going to have a lockdown
that is people are going to be in their
houses but if you're vaccinated you're
allowed to go about your normal business
if you're not you can't go more than 30
kilometers away from your house you
can't leave your house unless it's in a
medical emergency or to get emergency
supplies
i mean we've been saying this people
like myself have been saying this for
years now show us the evidence that
that's a reasonable statement because i
don't think there is any i'm pretty sure
you would agree that there isn't any and
we've seen this repeated all across the
country our state parliaments and our
territory governments have been acting
on advice they won't show us and you
know they have been quite prescriptive
in the types of
measures that have been brought in to to
stop people's movement to require mass
mandates to require vaccine mandates to
lock people in their homes
all based on science that they won't
show and that's part of the reason why
i've got myself into trouble i think
with some of our health bureaucrats is
because i keep asking for it i say show
us the evidence why is it that this is
important to have one set of rules for
people that have made a health choice
and another set of rules for another and
the silence is deafening absolutely
deafening yeah it is and uh i must tell
you i'm a scientist and i've looked
carefully at this and it's not that i
don't see the noise in the data i do but
there is nothing conclusive to support
the kinds of measures that are being
instituted
and i know that as a member of the west
our relationship with rights is
fundamental to our societal function and
the idea that bureaucrats most of them
unelected
are in a position to simply look at what
they think the evidence is and conclude
that ah it is the time to suspend our
rights and to behave um in a way that is
most decidedly not consistent with our
our uh our founding
values is preposterous i know as you've
just implied that we need to have a
discussion right there are circumstances
in which one does override liberty but
those are the most sobering of
circumstances and they require us to
have an open discussion of what the
evidence does imply and whether this is
indeed a moment that justifies that and
i know we didn't have that discussion
here in the u.s i'm i'm getting the
sense you didn't have it in australia
either
which raises the question you know what
is this really about is it is it about
protecting people from a disease or is
it about uh
enforcing compliance at all costs well i
think it's certainly become about
coercive power and control and that's my
strong view and i've said it time and
time again in this country and it does
push against the narrative a little bit
um we have um i think as i said a
similar set of circumstances in terms of
our political structure uh and then the
the us does and the detail of that is
probably too involved to go into for
today's purposes but effectively we have
a commonwealth government a federal
government which has two houses of
parliament um you have a senate and so
do we you have the house of congress and
we have a house of representatives now
the difference from our point of view
then drifts into the state parliament so
we have state parliaments all across the
country and we have one in each state
and territory
from from australia's point of view the
federal government the government of
which i'm a member um holds
some of the important
keys basically we we deal with funding
so we're we're the main taxation body um
we deal with the military um we deal
with finance related matters but the
states do basically the balance of the
rest and that's everything if you think
about what sort of powers that
encompasses that's medical powers
healthcare policing schools largely i
mean we fund the schools but you know
the the control of the schools all rests
with the state so you get this uneasy
balance between the states wanting to do
their own
thing and in many cases they're
different parties so one will be you
know our center right party the liberal
party and one will be uh from the labor
party and there's always that tension um
the states will want to set their agenda
but then they'll want the commonwealth
government to pay for it and we've seen
a bit of that in in the covert response
in that the states are really the ones
driving this and the state parliaments
all across our country
have almost universally and almost
systematically
enacted acts of parliament which
basically hand the reins of power to the
unelected bureaucracy and as you
describe it they did so on the basis
that we were waiting two weeks to
flatten the curve
we never signed up for this concept that
it would be two years and we would still
be doubling down on these powers i mean
if you'd said to me two years ago
that the northern territory would be
doing these sorts of things even a cynic
like myself would have said that's
ridiculous there's no point in doing
that but this is what's happened in in
australia and we've now got the
situation where unelected bureaucrats
are making calls
on all sorts of health directions
whether or not there are vaccine
mandates whether there are masks whether
there are lockdowns
and and
really with no recourse to the general
public no need to show their medical
evidence no need to justify their
actions
our chief health officers are the people
in control of those departments they've
become like celebrities here almost
daily we get updates from them and
people comment on the hairstyles and the
makeup and this and that
and in one sense we have lost i think
perspective on it you're very very
correct when you say these are
extraordinary powers giving away our
rights um are the sorts of things that
were done when these acts were
originally introduced so our emergency
management act in south australia
actually was designed for what we would
call a bushfire you'd call a forest fire
or a flood or an earthquake something
that would require a week not something
that requires two years so we're finding
that that
really when you when you come two years
down the track dealing with what has now
become basically an endemic situation
rather than a pandemic and you get all
the arguments about where that fitted in
originally
there really is no other way to look at
this other than i think the bureaucrats
don't want to get out of the warm bed of
coercive power and i think it's always
always a risk and it was my complaint
when the state parliament kept doing
this
how do you get the power back um how do
you wrench it back from people that have
set up you know almost effectively
departments and hired and fired people
based purely on setting up this little
fifetum
it's really really dangerous stuff it
requires strong political will from the
states in australia it's a will i
haven't seen yet
but that's why it's so important that we
we talk about it on shows like your own
because frankly the australian media has
become
lazy and weak
well i think this is becoming all the
more obvious if you know where to look
and in part that's because the focus of
these mandates has been these vaccines
for which the argument is getting
weaker by the hour
right now in the u.s we've gone through
this uh
period of gaslighting initially they
told us that the vaccines were going to
control the pandemic if only everyone
would get on board
that obviously isn't the case uh israel
um australia maybe best case gibraltar
tells us that even complete compliance
doesn't result in control of of the
pathogen
and so then we were told that actually
the only purpose of the vaccines was
ever to protect individuals from the
worst consequences of the disease
hospitalization and death and the like
um and you know we were told that it was
our imagination that anybody had ever
said anything different which was of
course easily documented nonsense um but
if it is true that the only purpose of
these vaccines is to protect individuals
from the extreme consequences
then uh obviously mandates are uh a bit
preposterous right you're removing
people's rights to protect them from the
remote chance that they will end up in a
hospital at best and then
with the uh spread of omicron
it's not even clear that the vaccinated
are better protected from contracting
the disease than the unvaccinated so you
know the the rationale is evaporated but
what i see is no change in tenor
whatsoever amongst our
uh elected leaders and our unelected
bureaucrats the point is
the answer is still vaccines and
boosters for everyone don't even
question it and
uh i mean it basically tells the story
that you're you're hinting at here which
is that
uh our
governmental structure is at best drunk
with power that they are reluctant to
give up having won it in an emergency
yeah i think that's a great way of
putting it it was almost a contest one
in an emergency and
you know from australia's point of view
i mean it's particularly worrying
because we
when you look around the world at the
sorts of countries that are you know
liberal democracies that that hold these
um truths and that that hold these it is
important on these powers um
we the united states canada new zealand
many of these countries were probably in
the minority in in across the world and
certainly from australia's point of view
as a power in the region or middle power
as we sometimes call ourselves we are
surrounded by um countries that don't
share our values on these views we've
we've had a long history in recent times
of pushing back on the on the chinese
communist party on their incursions into
into australia through the soft power
um
you know almost diplomatic means um we
were you know i guess leaders in the
world in terms of rejecting um the
huawei company build our 5g network
and we've taken enormous steps in terms
of our legislative arrangements to push
that influence away by digging into
influence in universities military
organizations so we've got a proud
history of of holding these values dear
and close to our heart and it feels
almost like within two years
um using this concept as it is an
emergency which is always the excuse
given um we've thrown the baby out with
the bath water now that's not to say
that it's
not you know recoverable i think it
absolutely is and i think and i hope it
will be but in the meantime um people
are being conditioned for a different
way of looking at things and
you know we've got two years now where
people have spent time and i don't i
don't think this is the same in the
united states but here in australia
in almost every state as i'm aware of it
people are required to check in using a
qr code wherever they go so if you go to
fill up your car with petrol you bring
your phone and you scan the qr code and
you check in and your data then gets
registered in a central database that
is held by the government and then when
you leave
you know you walk out you go to the next
shop you do the same thing so for
example people that have been christmas
shopping might have qr code checked into
10 shops in a day and a half
and then the idea is that of course if
someone's covered positive in that area
you get notified and you know into
quarantine you go sometimes into one of
these many hotels that we'll talk about
as well i don't think that's a
phenomenon the united states has
experienced but here in australia people
are now used to it they look for the
code
and the conditioning to accept this kind
of
soft power totalitarianism is now firmly
getting ingrained in australia's dna and
i think that's really worrying i'm
worried that people aren't more worried
about it frankly i mean there are there
are some that are but people like myself
who make these statements get accused of
being
um you know sort of conspiracy theorists
or whatever you might call
but i think the trajectory on this if
it's not arrested is really bad i worry
about this sort of persuasive social
credit style system that we can see
coming in
um and there's a number of examples of
that south australia in fact my home
state um the health bureaucracy here are
the the authors of the home quarantine
app which is a
in my view a dreadful piece of software
which sits on your phone um and the
rationale for it was that instead of
being quarantined somewhere else you can
buy your freedom by agreeing to sign up
to this app
and
it contacts you three times a day it
requires you to show a picture of your
face or live stream your face it takes
the gps data from that it triangulates
that information and sends it back to
police headquarters
and confirms that you're at home where
you said you'd be at home
and if you're not then you get a knock
on the door from the police now
people seem to have accepted that in
this country as being oh well that's
terrific that means i don't have to go
into a midi hotel which is a detainment
facility here um and it's sort of almost
a way of buying your freedom back well
you know i would say to that
my freedom is not something the
government gives me it's it's you know
as it should be in the united states and
as it should be here it's it's an
inalienable right uh so we've become
very conditioned to accepting the
unacceptable over the last two years and
i think that's really the the difficulty
we're gonna face is winding that back
and winding back these ideas from a
bureaucracy that never has to face up to
an electorate nobody who came up with
that idea is ever going to have to
justify it in front of a ballot box
well you're absolutely right that in the
united states the government is not
allowed to track your every move using
your phone only google has that right
[Laughter]
i mean i i'm joking of course but google
has effectively taken that right and we
have been conditioned to just simply uh
accept it and so this is you know
another bigger step and i must tell you
that just hearing about the idea that oh
by the way your phone has the ability to
detect whether it's actually your face
because of course your phone does have
that ability and your phone knows
exactly where on earth it is and that
does mean that somebody who avails
themselves of the privilege of knowing
whether or not you are at home is uh in
a position to check up on you and yeah
that sounds um like a brand new
high-tech kind of totalitarianism for
which we do not have an exact historical
precedent but oh my god here it comes
yeah and of course it's been sold to the
people of south australia is aren't you
proud you know your local health
bureaucracy has created this wonderful
software look at what the public service
can do
but of course we know that that would
have required
you know a separate budget line into the
department it would have required hiring
staff it requires that fifedom to build
and it requires
then a massive massive step to go back
to a time where you didn't have those
resources around you and what we're
seeing in australia of course is this
drift into big government and i think
one of our problems here is that we do
think as australians i think more than
we should
the government can solve our problems
and that's probably one of the lines
where we've drifted from
um you know the united states uh i think
has a much different view of it i mean
we had a series of bush fires in this
country a year and a half ago two years
ago
and
the incessant line was why is the
government fixing this i mean these are
natural disasters
but the australian idea in many ways
sadly is that government should fix
these things and and we've become
indelibly marked with the thumbprint of
big government in this country and i and
i and i think that's as concerning as as
anything we have
we don't have a bill of rights here
there's that was i said an entirely
different discussion for whether or not
that's a good thing or a bad thing um
but what it has done is highlighted some
of the deficiencies in our system the
system of federation that's allowed the
states as we described earlier to hold
powers in their own little hand
to block off their borders to travel and
to do what they've done but then also
this issue of the individuals rights and
um that's a big that's a big can of
worms we probably aren't going to open
today but but
you know we're starting to see the
fruits of those those decisions back in
1901 in australia
so there are a number of differences
that are becoming clear
one just a structural difference is that
there's an inversion in your system from
the american system where your states
are more powerful than your federal
government
and that of course is at least part of
the explanation for why some australians
are looking out their window and saying
this is all made up in some sense i
don't get it entirely because presumably
every australian has access to michael
gunner and they can listen to him
say uh his uh you know his deranged
ranting and his punishing of the
unvaccinated and
they can infer that the uh
the
unrest that they are seeing in in
melbourne is about something so they
should be able to put two and two
together but nonetheless i suppose a
certain kind of
sampling of the environment around you
if you're in a state that uh isn't
engaged in uh draconian measures at the
same level might be reassuring
um whereas there are parts of
your country in which uh
things are apparently jaw-dropping
including the government checking on you
to see whether
you've gone home
even though at some level as has been
true throughout the pandemic these
measures don't make a lot of sense
epidemiologically
right
it's not obvious that you you know going
out to take a hike or a walk with your
dog is a threat to anybody right so you
know that's right that's right and look
even those things have been restricted
in australia over the last two years
we've have even in this state where we
haven't had as many lockdowns as as the
state of victoria has but we've had them
here where
you know there's been directives on
going out and getting some exercise in
the fresh air in a park with nobody
around you and you would have seen all
of those images of people in new south
wales which is a further eastern state
it's the the state which is the capital
is sydney
where police have been telling people to
move on on bondi beach sitting on a
beach on their own with nobody around
them and and that is the very nature of
the you know the draconian nature there
is no
room for
common sense in that scenario it just
happens
and look there are so many other
examples as well i mean i talked a
little bit before about this concept of
the medi hotel and i don't that's that's
something which i don't think americans
have experienced thankfully but
um this this
i suppose drift into quarantining and
quarantining at home quarantining in old
hotels and quarantining of course in
these quarantine camps as well uh is
something that australians have become
too
um i suppose familiar with in too short
a period of time we have um hotels here
which have basically been repurposed for
two years they're just standard hotels
in the middle of the city here in
adelaide the capital city of south
australia there are about three one of
them is an old apartment block but
they're basically um hotels that have a
big metal fence around them police
walking around down the bottom
and people who've mostly come from
overseas and are doing their 14 days
quarantining or seven or depending
whatever the dictator of the day is um
and
they are like little prisons and i mean
people
in this country roll their eyes at that
suggestion those who don't who aren't
worried about what's going on but the
reality is anytime your liberty is
restricted um that's a bad thing it
doesn't matter if you're doing it in a
five-star hotel or if you're behind bars
in a maximum security prison the reality
is as soon as you can't leave your front
door for fear of
penalty
you are
locked down your liberty is restricted
so we're seeing that time and time again
we also have governments now having gone
through that experience as a way of
dealing with quarantining and lockdowns
expanding that out now into this concept
that i know has made a lot of media in
the united states of um of quarantine
facilities they use they try not to use
the word camps but the reality is
they're large transportable units
they're popping up over the country
we've got the major one in the northern
territory where mr gunner is the chief
minister
which is called howard springs that made
a bit of news a month or so ago with a
young lady who
was put into that facility simply for
the crime of walking with someone who
alongside someone who who had covert she
was
captured on a local cctv camera the
person i think was pushing a motorbike
and had therefore had a license plate
there which was recognizable
the contact tracing system identified
her and then identified this lady she
got a knock on the door from the police
and off she went for two weeks in this
facility having never tested positive
for covert so um but i want to ask you
about that though
um
this sounds like and i must say it's not
totally unprecedented i know that this
exists in the us in a form most
americans are probably not familiar with
but it sounds to me
like she was effectively
convicted of a crime
and sentenced to an admittedly short
sentence in what is effectively a prison
without a court having been involved is
that right yeah that's exactly right and
it's not it's not too long about a draw
i mean many would say that's overstating
it
but the reality is there is no right of
review if you've been charged with a
crime um you have appeal rights and you
have all of those here because of the
nature and the way in which these
schemes have been so you have none and
and so you are you are certainly i mean
and i think as i said that home
quarantine app that i described is a
much more draconian measure than you
would get for
um you know an offender who's been
sentenced to
home detention you know we would have a
home detention bracelet here under our
legal system
there's never been a requirement to make
people use biometric facial data and
gps's as far as i'm aware anyway
so i think i think although it does seem
sometimes those
comparisons are unfair i think there's a
it's a very slippery slope and it's a
question of what you become accustomed
to as a society
australians have become in my view too
accustomed to these restrictions on
liberty and in fact one of the things
that's been really alarming has been the
extent to which australians have become
accustomed to it
and i you know i think that this is why
the message needs to be out there we
know that from from polling that's been
done i did a bit of polling from my own
office that in south australia somewhere
between 30 and 40 of people felt
compelled to get a vaccination so we've
effectively bullied
hundreds of thousands of people we're a
state of about 1.7 million so on those
numbers we have effectively bullied and
coerced that many people into getting a
medical treatment that they weren't
otherwise going to want to so people
have become very accustomed to doing
what they're told
and if that isn't alarming then i i just
don't know
what is
well you're doing an admirable job
you're bending over backwards not to be
alarmist right you keep cautioning me
about the possibility of over
interpreting these things and and my
feeling is
we shouldn't get uh
too bent out of shape about the
imprecision you know is it a detention
camp
well i don't know
it doesn't really matter if it's a
detention camp the question is if it's
not a detention camp is there some other
thing that we're aware of that it is
more like than a detention camp and if
the answer is not obviously then the
question is all right why are we playing
around with something that is plausibly
a detention camp right can we look back
at history at the number of times that
we've done this and how we felt about it
afterwards and say
you know what are we doing as i've said
on my podcast what are we doing
in this part of the library
right why are we looking at the nazis
and the nuremberg trials and saying well
how precisely you know applicable are
these standards and the answer is it
doesn't precision has nothing to do with
it the fact that we're even looking at
the nuremberg code and saying hey wait a
minute what are we up to here tells us
we've found ourselves in territory we
don't want to be in and
you know it's also i keep reminding
myself
true that we are doing this
this isn't smallpox right i have never
been somebody who has minimized the
danger of covid in fact i was very early
on the idea that covid was more
dangerous than it appeared
that the case fatality rate did not
capture the damage that the disease does
and that we should all be very cautious
about it but that said
it is not that lethal a disease and for
you australians it's even less lethal
because you don't have a tremendous
problem with it you have a much better
controlled problem and yes those who are
in favor of these measures might argue
that your excellent control of it is the
result of these measures on the other
hand it may have to do with your
proximity to the equator and therefore
levels of vitamin d you're being an
island you know there are a lot of
factors that contribute but nonetheless
the question is
you've got these extreme measures that
in some sense have no parallel other
than
many of the worst chapters of history at
the same time you have a disease that
while yes it's not the flu is also not
so extreme that it's obvious we should
turn
upside down
all of the hard one rights in the west
uh in order to control it especially
when controlling it has been something
we've obviously failed that
yeah i think that's a great summary and
i like the analogy about being in the
section of the library
you you don't really want to be and i
mean that's very very true and
i'm seeing that out in the community as
i talk to people as i talk to people
privately i hear much more concern than
i do publicly and one of my great
frustrations is
that in essence
and i think there's probably a thesis in
this for someone who will write it at
some stage but it's hard to know
whether the tail is wagging the dog or
the dog's wagging the tail in many
respects the the media in this country
and i'm sure this will
raise their eye out but have been so
complicit and so lazy and so hopeless
with reporting what's going on in this
country
that the political class i think have
followed that sniffing the wind
and we now have a generation of
politicians
with a few exceptions of course along
the way
who are simply waving through
bureaucratic power like they were
standing at a set of stoplights
without recourse and with a great deal
of fear um about being the person that
stands up and says you know what i'm not
okay with this myself and this is not
i'm not saying this to to sort of you
know for any other purpose than just to
make the the point myself and a senator
from queensland by the name of gerard
renick um last sitting period um told
the prime minister that he didn't have
our vote until such time as we took
steps to
address vaccine discrimination mandates
which is difficult because the federal
government only has so many strength
support for reasons we've discussed
already but there are things we can do
there are funding issues there you know
there are there are methods to fix this
if we want to now that hasn't borne
fruit yet but to take that step was
almost seen as being
disloyal
and in australia there is a lot more
party discipline i think than perhaps
there is the united states i know
members of each major political party in
the united states do freelance more and
but in australia that's a very very
unusual thing the two-party system is
largely um rock-solid
but the political class just hasn't you
know almost universally just hasn't
stood up to this and that's what it is
going to take it needs people to become
more vocal to have those conversations
they're having privately with people you
know this perception going around that
you know does this all seem right to you
it doesn't seem right to me what is this
all about these are conversations that
are being had in the house not in the
town square at the moment uh for fear of
derision for fear of excommunication
from political circles um but i've said
it time and time again i'm only two
years into a you know what maybe a short
or a long political career but in in
terms of where i sit this is a hill i'm
prepared to die on because these are
fundamental issues we've we've always
hailed our robustness our adaptability
and our resilience
in this uh democracy here but
if we have fought hard to protect these
institutions then we have to continue to
fight hard
not only on the international scene as
we've done with the united states in
multiple wars but also domestically we
have to stand up for these freedoms and
these rights
and we're seeing a dangerous drift in
this country something like 30 percent
of 18 to 29 year olds apparently have a
view that a non-democratic way of
approach in
you know politics is okay is reasonable
um you know that is alarming and we've
seen this sort of long march into the
institutions that i know has happened in
the united states as well this kind of
pervasive soft totalitarian approach
invading schools and universities
my concern is that we're now going to
get a generation of people that think
what is happening is okay that soft
totalitarianism is going to approach and
that we're going to end up with this
dreadful
social credit style system that rules
our lives for the benefit of who knows
yeah i i i exactly agree with you and
you know we have a constant problem
which is that uh
anything that has been well addressed by
our system is more or less invisible and
so this issue of chesterton's fence is
constantly dogging us you know the west
is not perfect it's got a lot that could
be improved um but it is
tremendously dynamic and productive and
overwhelmingly fairer than the other
alternative systems and so
if you see its imperfections and you
think well look at all it's doing wrong
let's get rid of it you have no idea how
many of the things that it has actually
accomplished you're about to get rid of
until they're gone and so i think you
and i are watching
uh the the gains of the west slip away
and uh it's it's hard it's hard to raise
people's awareness of what in fact they
are playing with but
you you point to this other
issue which is what happens when you do
talk candidly to other people and i i'm
here in portland oregon portland oregon
uh i think is arguably
the uh
farthest left
city in the country
in
what might be the farthest left state
right we're here on the west coast with
california and washington
but nonetheless in terms of mandates we
have the strongest in the country we're
the farthest out at that end of the
continuum and yet
when i talk to people here in portland
there is not overwhelming agreement that
this is sensible and that everybody
needs to get on board what there is is a
tremendous amount of skepticism that
this makes any sense whatsoever but you
don't hear that if you only listen to
the official discourse so
what you describe with your media
that they are what did you say waving
through these uh draconian measures like
they were just passing traffic through
an intersection or something i think
that yeah words that affect you um
this is really
in some sense it's a magic trick right
there's an illusion that we are in that
the good people are all in agreement
about these measures being necessary in
order to control this pandemic because
this is how we feel people are beginning
to talk openly with each other outside
of others earshot but nobody including
me has any idea what the actual balance
of belief is there has been such a
strong effort to penalize people for
voicing uh a minority perspective on
this that you know the minority might in
fact be in the majority and we would
never know it right we would never know
it because people are afraid to confess
what they believe
that's exactly right and we see that
time and time again and i
and i think one of the other moving
parts in there has been this what must
be a deliberate attempt
to continue to push genuine
misinformation out there which is things
which are facts facts factoids like
the vaccines will stop transmission you
are protecting grammar if you if you
take it um
those bits of data which clearly are
wrong or you know are largely wrong are
still
i think influencing people's thought
processes given armed with the proper
facts i think we'd see a quantum shift
um in in in you know in sort of the
approach but at the moment the fear is
dictating the day and of course
like everybody else and i'm sure you did
as well i listened to joe rogan's
podcast with
dr robert malone the other day where he
summarized the thing that i i mean i
used to call it stockholm syndrome but
mass formation psychosis is actually a
better way of looking at it injecting
fear into society
and allowing people in numbers to run
around and
you know whale flail their arms around
like everyone's going to die is a very
surefire way to i suppose erase the
concepts of
you know science and rational thought
and liberty and freedom and democracy so
i mean that is probably the most clever
um synopsis i've heard in recent times
and i think has done enormous favor to
people who are wanting to talk about
this more freely and more openly frankly
we need it i mean from a political point
of view my concept has always been how
do we how do we achieve this when there
are only outlets like yours
you know who are talking in in in
genuine
scientific terms about the things that
are going on people like joe
and others how do we get that message
out there
and how do we get business leaders
politicians and the general public to
feel as though they can say
i'm worried about healthcare like you
are i'm worried about the concept of a
global pandemic but i'm also worried
about what we're doing to our freedom
and our liberty these are things that
which are our democracy has been built
on for years on end how do we make sure
they don't get you know one doesn't
snuff the other out and vice versa but
at the moment that that conversation is
just not us not an acceptable one for
the australian media or the australian
public we have to try and make it so
because you know frankly australia is a
critical a critical plank in the liberal
democracies of the world over and we
just can't see this being thrown out
with the bath water yeah it's one of the
places i would have thought that if uh
if the walls came tumbling down here in
the us that it would have been
the right place to run and i no longer
think that because
you appear to be ahead of us in terms of
what you have accepted in the erosion of
your
your rights
um i wanted to add something you
mentioned that if people actually
had a a a decent understanding of the
facts of sars kovi ii kovid 19
the vaccines etc that they would have a
very different perspective on what was
reasonable
and i
wholeheartedly believe that i mean your
example of people being kicked off the
beach those people being kicked off the
beach were presumably
at essentially no risk of catching or
transmitting covet to anybody
irrespective of who had coveted because
at least so far as we know it has not
transmitted maybe this has changed with
obacron but has not transmitted well
outdoors
the other thing though is sitting there
on a beach in australia they were
probably making vitamin d which turns
out to be terrifically important vitamin
d deficiencies which most of us here in
the northern climes suffer from are
actually
a key factor in the vulnerability to
diseases beyond covet 19 but very much
including it and so you know here you
have a government strong-arming people
who are actually doing something
probably useful against this very
disease strong arming them into doing
something harmful go inside
right where the disease does transmit
and where you're not making vitamin d so
that is at least a massive
error but the missing thing here
is at the same time that our governments
are
mandating things that make no sense and
failing to convey a proper model for
this disease or
the remedy that they are pushing they
are also blocking the use of other
remedies that do seem to work and there
are many doctors who have discovered
protocols that are highly effective
and they are finding themselves uh
uh unlicensed fired
um and you know they are having their
prescriptions blocked at the pharmacy so
you know not only
are people not possessed of the facts
but their doctors are being robbed of
the tools that would be useful and so
really it all suggests a desire to keep
people in a frightened and vulnerable
state
which then just so happens to make an
argument for draconian measures whereas
doctors who are getting smarter over the
course of a pandemic of how to treat
this disease and are now in a position
to manage it very effectively scientists
are getting smarter about it who can now
tell us hey actually that behavior that
you know we were forbidding it turns out
to be totally safe why don't you go to
the beach spend as much time there as
possible right these things would change
our approach if the purpose was to
protect people from the pandemic if this
has become as you say about the
accumulation of power
then of course those things would uh be
a material
yeah that's right and another great
example of that has been
the interplay between lockdowns and
exercise and you know we know that
people who are fit and healthy who are
getting exercise and you know who are
living that sort of lifestyle are better
prepared for the effects of covert and
of course what's their reaction been in
some states it's been to lock people in
their homes where they're drinking more
alcohol their mental health is suffering
and their fitness levels are dropping um
you know remarkably and we've seen
demonstrable levels of mental health
problems coming out of victoria which
has had those 260 odd days in lockdown
um so look you're absolutely right and i
and i think look i i always
have difficulty with the concept of
talking about the other alternatives
treatments because i i'm not a doctor
and i don't pretend to be and i don't
have any background in science as is
evident uh but um but i i what i can say
is that the the thing that alarms me out
of all of that is the fact that we have
had no debate about it in this country
um like in the united states uh
therapeutic goods association which is
effectively our fda
uh has just said uh it said at one point
i think uh six months ago that
alternative treatments such as
hydroxychloroquine and ivamectin are
just not available they just won't be
used and we're not going to talk about
it and when asked the question why it is
they've referred back to all of the
talking points which are well in a
certain dose it's very very dangerous
and you know we can't have that being
run around and this is the official line
and so doctors in this country are
intimidated they have been intimidated
threatened with loss of registration um
and those sorts of things are entirely
anti-science and illiberal um they're
the sort of things that you just can't
imagine would happen in any other
circumstance so why now what what is the
difference with this than we would have
had had we had an outbreak of
tuberculosis or had we had an outbreak
of you know smallpox even who knows you
know something like that it escaped
we're seeing things that we just that
just don't seem to make sense in terms
of a pandemic response in some aspects
uh and i i find that the most concerning
thing that the shutdown in thought and
the shutdown in discussion is as
important an issue as any that we've had
because um some of these things require
more discussion than zero that's for
sure and that's about what we've got at
the moment yes it's uh there's the
public discussion there's the scientific
discussion and there's also the medical
discussion and i think the the thing
that most people most citizens don't
really understand is that part of the
way medicine works
is that your doctor really is supposed
to be a scientist and when confronted
with some kind of new disease they are
supposed to as frightening as this is
take their best shot at helping you and
in so doing they discover what works and
they talk to each other and the problem
is what we now have is a draconian
top-down mandate that says here are some
substances you are not allowed to try
right here are some substances that many
people believe work including many
doctors who have used them you are not
allowed to prescribe them and that is a
fundamental inversion of the way
medicine is supposed to work and what it
does is it prevents the process in which
we get better at saving people
right it blocks that process and so you
know you look at your window you don't
see that anything has changed but that's
a radical alteration in the relationship
between you your doctor your pharmacist
and your government right it's a it's a
major inversion and one that has
tremendous implications for your
well-being not just for covid but for
everything else as well
yeah that's exactly right and they are
the sorts of things that that's sort of
the sanctity of that relationship with
uh with the medical practitioner has has
been eroded and i mean i i know for a
fact there are many doctors out there
who
uh who are frightened to talk about
other ways of dealing with this and now
simply don't have those tools that
they're at their um disposal either um
and of course you know we've also got um
the situation i think where people um
you know having these conversations
themselves in between you know their own
medical
outlet and and feeling as though they're
doing something wrong by talking about
you know things that you've talked about
simple things vitamin d getting a bit of
sunlight well what's the harm in that i
mean you can't hurt yourself so nobody's
ever suggesting that this is the only
cure it's just a question of the
discussion about whether or not there
are other things that can be done
exercise vitamin d
they're not being they're not being
discussed in this country at the moment
and we're seeing that time and time
again with
i suppose with the the medical response
but
you know i i mean i i just i i see that
level um because you know that's the
game we're in politics i'm not sure that
that people on the street say that
people are expected and entitled to take
the advice of the regulatory bodies
you know as as given because in this
country they have always been
outstanding i mean we have some of the
best medical care
in the world we have a universal health
care system which works really well
medicare here where people nobody is out
of hospital ever really other than
extreme circumstances but also we've now
got a society where having had that and
built that system up to you know one of
the world's best systems i'd say
we're now getting political leaders
heads of professional bodies like our
australian medical association in
various places making comments like if
you haven't taken the vaccine perhaps
you shouldn't be entitled to healthcare
at all you know completely flying in the
face of our universal healthcare model
and it sort of highlights once again
what has happened here that the sorts of
things that were unthinkable two years
ago are now being discussed openly i
mean if you said to someone
two years ago if you haven't
had a
measles injection then you shouldn't be
entitled to health care you would have
been laughed at
you had your medical registration pulled
but now that seems to be an acceptable
statement in public discourse a few of
those people have been shouted down of
course but not in the manner they should
have been i mean these are ridiculous
statements and it's worrying that's
crept into even the medical profession
well it goes to uh your point about mass
formation that this is
not in the least unfamiliar it just
comes from the chapters of history we at
least want to revisit right the
dehumanizing of people and the uh the
justification of the elimination of
their rights because they're not fully
human and they don't deserve them right
that's uh that's not new uh
it's just new enough that people aren't
familiar with what that sound uh
uh leads towards and
i wish they were i wish they were
thinking more carefully about it because
you know again we're in the wrong we're
in the wrong section of the library and
we ought to be very frightened that this
is where our analogies are coming from
um i know
uh
you've again done an excellent job being
very careful in your presentation
making sure not to exaggerate or
use hyperbole
but i did want to ask you
you have personally
had a
run-in with
what maybe we're not supposed to call
detention or camps or whatever i'm not i
haven't gotten the memo that tells me
what i am supposed to call it um but uh
what happened
yeah well look i have and and i mean i
use that term quite openly i'm pretty
comfortable with it detention is when
you cannot leave so being detained is
what it is so i you won't offend me i
can assure you but um the um the the
scenario here
obviously in my job um i travel a lot
because you know a member of the the
government and we travel to canberra
which is effectively our washington i
sit in the senate over there um so it's
required a lot of travel there have been
periods where we haven't but throughout
the course of the last two years um
we have seen a different way of doing it
every time on very early on when we
would leave we would come back from the
australian capital territory which is
where cambria is we would probably
quarantine at home for two weeks and we
got used to doing that then as things
subsided a bit we didn't at all we would
just return to normal life as i think
has been the case in the united states
crossing boundaries
um
as the days and weeks went on and the
healthcare bureaucracies decided that
you know they would become more
prescriptive with their rules and
requirements these these almost
visa-like arrangements between
travelling between states started to
emerge
during our last trip which was back in
november
i left the state with one set of rules
and came back to a different set of
rules
what that meant was that by the time i
was coming back i was required as we're
all parliamentarians to apply for
the right to return to my home uh
through a specially crafted and i'm sure
very clever system um
through the internet the entry check
system which had been developed here
i was denied twice the ability to come
home
and
you know you fill in the ask the
questions and so on and so forth and
then ultimately
i was told that i needed to go into a
midi hotel um for 14 days uh with no
right of review and i i mean you know
that has happened before but it hasn't
happened in any of the other previous
um
you know scenarios when we've been
traveling
and of course the thing that really
stuck out in my mind the thing that
started to really um raise concerns
about the rationale for that was the
fact that after 10 minutes of being told
that i got a call from a journalist who
also knew about it
who knew about all the details in the
same language that the the email that
i'd received telling me about it um and
then i was met by photographers and
media at the airport in order to
document the whole thing and frankly the
exercise is not as bad as it looks i in
fact looked for the officials to tell
them i think i'm apparently told i need
to go into a midi hotel but those
officials are police officers so the
scene looked like you were being
detained and dragged away which you sort
of were but it wasn't quite as draconian
as that but once again
the next day in our local newspaper that
was splashed across the front you know
antic detained you know so on and so
forth and i spent
14 days there despite having had a
covered test
i think uh the day before leaving and
then we'll count them up six during my
time in the hotel
um
and no ability to get out and i was
taken to a medi hotel once again metal
fence around the bottom police there
um you know three meals brought to your
door um
you know during the day with a knock on
the door like you're in you're in a
prison environment um you can't leave to
get the uh the meal more than three
minutes before it's left and you can't
leave it out there longer than 10
minutes for in the reasons of science
presumably who knows why um and you know
checks every day on your mental health
and i kept saying well i'm fine but i'd
be better if you'd let me go home
and yeah all this sort of stuff you know
and so it was a nice hotel in the middle
of the city not far from where i've
worked before but if you can't leave
that environment you are in there so
what's the message that has been sent
i've spent the last six months poking
around the local health bureaucracy who
are the you know the really the ones
that made that decision asking for
documents asking for information asking
them to show us the science that we're
meant to trust
uh and then fell on the receiving end of
that little trick on the way through and
of course um the last 24 hours here in
australia have seen
the world number one tennis player novak
djokovic go through a similar experience
he also is of serbian extraction so i'm
not going to suggest for a minute
there's some sort of serbian
anti-serbian conspiracy in australia i
would only say that in jest but um the
the similarities are frightening he's
currently in a midi hotel in melbourne
um
to the best of my knowledge with no
symptoms of covert
and that really is the question here
where's the science that says
whatever it turns out to be the case
whether he's there's an issue with
vaccination or not or exemptions or not
where's the science that says
allowing him in if he can test
negative even you know despite the fact
that there are a hundred thousand cases
of covert floating around in our
community across the country
where is the science that says that's a
reasonable thing to do and what is the
reality for reputational damage for our
country um when this sort of stuff is
happening i mean i we just don't know
the details yet that matters in front of
the courts at the moment but um this
business of taking people and locking
them up against their will as you said
earlier quite rightly it doesn't matter
if it's in a five-star hotel and you're
sitting around a pool if i can't leave
if you can't leave then you're being
detained it's as simple as that and that
is happening too commonly in this
country at the moment
so it sounds to me
uh
like both you and mr djokovic
were
imprisoned
to prevent you from transmitting a
disease to others that neither of you
apparently had
i think that's about right i think
that's a very very apt summary here
it does not
i mean things may be different south of
the equator but north of the equator
that doesn't sound like it's logical to
me it just sounds um beyond preposterous
in fact
it's hard to even know what to make of
it and i you know i think you know you
said soft totalitarianism uh i have used
the term surgical totalitarianism
there is something to the idea of
we are being broken in
on accepting certain things that
ourselves from two or three years ago
would have uh balked at in the strongest
possible terms
i'm not sure even what to say about it
except at some level just
people need to listen to the description
of what has happened they need to hear
you not leaping to conclusions about it
not saying anything beyond what actually
happened just the simple facts of it and
ask themselves
are we being
governed
by rational people in our collective
interest or is something else going on
because
increasingly i don't think any of this
actually squares the with the idea that
people who
are obsessed with our medical well-being
are perhaps a bit carried away i don't
think you can explain this that way this
looks like something
is uh
taking a kind of power that we never
would have given up absent an emergency
and it doesn't look like it's planning
to give it back
no and we say that all the time here i
mean every day um things seem to slip
again you know we we see this
that story about the northern territory
yesterday um is something that was
unexpected because it felt as though
we'd moved past all of that and as you
say in a temporary environment where
i think the terminology used in this
state is a major emergency has been
declared and has been declared for two
years you would assume that that major
emergency would you know evaporate but
of course we're not seeing that at all
in fact if if anything i think we're
seeing it getting ratcheted up in some
some aspects so
look it doesn't make sense what it is
doing of course is and this is another
entire limb but a societal limb is it's
dividing australians and the anecdotal
evidence from the christmas period is
that it was a
probably was the same in the united
states a sort of a fraught period where
families were fighting amongst
themselves because of whether people
wanted to even congregate in numbers at
all in this state as we speak right now
uh health bureaucrats have dictated that
you cannot have more than 10 people in
your home
for any reason as far as i'm aware um
you know and and businesses can't have
more than 25 percent of their normal
uh customer flow so throughout that new
year period um businesses were just
hemorrhaging hemorrhaging money their
hard costs of rent and electricity they
don't change
small businesses are
facing this this critical period
families are facing this critical period
and it doesn't seem to be getting any
better and we are seeing that division
rolling out through this country and i
you know like everybody who's involved
in the public sphere and the public town
hall you know sort of sitting i try to
speak to people about it as rationally
as i can and i say
do you think you would understand this
if i was to come back to you in in two
three five years and you know you had an
app on your phone that told you you
couldn't buy another tank of petrol gas
you know
today because we're in the middle of a
climate emergency because
you know in one sense
it is hard to imagine a time
where this won't continue if we don't
stop it now where social credit as we
see in places like china
isn't you know at least more persuasive
in here and we were just told this week
that in south australia there's a meat
shortage
you know i'm sure there's a rational
explanation for that but
you know it also sounds a little bit
like um
you know
we have been hearing out of the world
economic forum we have to cut down on
meat and these sorts of things you know
where does this stop do we end up
becoming a country that is dominated by
uh the naughty or nice register that
sits on our phone
and are people live enough to it and
will people you know when for example
they go to the bottle shop uh to buy you
know a carton of beer and can't do it
because you know they've already had one
this week is that enough to wake people
up um because at the moment i don't
think that uh those lines of uh of sort
of thought have been joined but i i fear
they're coming and i fear we need more
people to speak up
well if i can
say what i think i heard you just say in
different terms
it seems to me that there are
basically two possible systems
you can have a system in which your
bureaucracy
is empowered
to
decide
when your rights apply and when your
your rights don't apply based on
emergencies of which there will be many
in which case
i don't know whether your climate
example is sensible or not but it's
certainly no more preposterous than what
we are seeing now so you know is it
acceptable for
our governments of the west to decide
well the time has come to uh
to eliminate your rights uh over
climate or
racism or whatever else it's going to do
um
or are we going to have a system
in which
the only
thing the only tool our bureaucrats have
should they wish to relieve us of our
rights is persuasion where they actually
have to convince us that this in fact
does merit that step
and
i think you know those of us who are
paying attention have now seen enough of
this to know that there is only one
right answer to that question a system
in which they have to persuade us
to put aside those rights temporarily
because something necessitates it is the
only tolerable system one in which they
are empowered to decide when we are in
that situation is one that is
automatically going to be abused uh
until we until we uh until we change it
yeah exactly and i think um
one of the things we've uh handing power
in the manner that we have in this
country to our bureaucrats is it's never
it's never taken that system into
account it's never it's never required
any explanation to be given and i know
there are many doctors that say well
hang on where's the evidence for that
you know where is they're saying it
privately of course um you know show us
the data on this show us the the the
rationale that's been that's been used
in order to adopt this line of um
approach and there isn't any and
as you say the the rationale given for
not that is it's an emergency we don't
have time just let's get on with it um
now i think you're absolutely right if
if things are to continue in this matter
then people
are entitled to an explanation you know
if it is a climate emergency if
um then explain it and give us the data
and it needs to be a discussion not just
a selection of your favorite expert
reports that favor your political
narrative it needs to be a proper
facilitated process i mean even here in
in this country if we had had a system
whereby
um the decision-making process was
vetted by those who were elected so that
the rules were put back through you know
a committee or a an elected body of some
sort then there would be some oversight
there would be some skin in the game for
the politicians
unfortunately around the country here um
you know i've been using the term
the politicians have effectively thrown
the keys to the bureaucrats and said all
right you take it from here um you know
we'll just we're just going to get out
and talk the talking points now that
hasn't been the case universally but
we've seen that you know in states like
victoria we've seen it in states like
queensland and western australia here
where
um you know they have they have
basically been selling the message of
the bureaucracy now that's that's not
the job of the politician the
politicians job is to direct the
bureaucracy uh and we have drifted from
that and you know i think there'll be
some interesting discussions in this
country hopefully that come out of this
period questions about
federation things like the bill of
rights i mean that's been a discussion
in australia and from my side of
politics it's always something that
people push back on because there is a
concern that
left-wing judges we'll we'll use that in
a certain way but i think what we've
seen now is enough to have a
broad-ranging conversation after this
and because
what we are doing at the moment is not
achieving everything we needed to
yeah well not only not only that but now
that i think about it it's one step
worse it's not even that the bureaucrats
have uh carte blanche to relieve us of
our rights when they decide that
something is important enough
but if you look at the media environment
and what has happened to those of us who
have
attempted to point out that none of this
fits our evidence about this disease
none of it adds up
we've been routinely
deplatformed and stigmatized and had
major pr campaigns uh set against us
so the point is those of us with no
power whatsoever accept the ability to
persuade people that something is amiss
are facing an incredible onslaught right
they don't have to they don't have to
convince us of anything and we're not
allowed to convince anyone that things
are are off and that is
truly a frightening uh circumstance yeah
it is and the point you make about the
ability to control the narrative from
the media point of view i don't think
has ever been more controlled than it is
now we see all the arguments it's still
an infant argument in australia about
big tech and the control of companies
like that
i've moved for that to become a feature
of
the discussion in our parliament i moved
for a fairly important select committee
to be established in the senate and it
was shot down by one vote um i don't
think that message is quite rolled out
through the australian political class
yet it doesn't matter whether you're
from the left or from the right
if if there is the ability to control
the discussion that power balance can
swing as soon as
as soon as you like so you know the
ability to be able to share this
information
um and to be able to talk about it
without being labeled in a pejorative
sense uh one you know an anti-vaxxer a
conspiracy theorist has has almost been
lost in the short term and the ability
to be able to bring that back is going
to be a real challenge we used to see
that in a different way in this country
we have for the longest time had media
ownership laws which
were you know crafted decades ago for
the purpose of making sure that one
particular person company entity or
whatever it might be can't get control
of the narrative in order to influence
politics well that seems to have been
completely overridden now by this global
push for big tech which can
you know change the debate with the
blink of an eye and i think that's a
massive problem and it's one that's been
really exacerbated by by the pandemic i
think well um you talk about a time
after the pandemic i admit i'm not yet a
believer in such a time
but i'm certainly hopeful that you're
right that it comes
i guess my biggest concern is that
this
this pandemic has
uh revealed a great deal about who is
susceptible to what
what sits in people's blind spots what
kinds of erosion of rights can happen
under your nose without you noticing
and my hope is that people will be
honest with themselves and with each
other in the aftermath of this and that
we do have a reckoning across the west
what does this imply about the security
of our rights and
uh the ability of our system to endure a
shock and to continue on
rather than to be transformed into
something abhorrent
i i guess i would have to uh
i would have to bet against such a
reckoning but i certainly hope that it
happens because
really um
this will not be the last time
that government overreaches and if we
don't learn the lesson of this pandemic
then i don't think we're going to be in
a good position to resist
no you're right brett and i think also
what we've seen i mean in this country
particularly is a um
the green shoots of
hope i think um a lot of these arise
from the protests that have been coming
out of places like victoria we've had
them here in south australia as well but
we have seen
uh they're called freedom rallies here
in australia and and they're much
derided by the press
we haven't seen crowds like this in this
country i mean arguably ever but
certainly not since the vietnam war
and they are almost given no coverage at
all they are they are
ignored by the mainstream media here
they are they are
you know mostly derided as being um
tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists
i've been to them i've spoken at one and
every time i go there i see everyday
people who are worried about the fact
that they've been mandated they're
losing their jobs they've got mortgages
to pay
but the really interesting thing is this
that if you want to see australia as it
is and at the beating heart of australia
i keep saying to people freedom rallies
are where you'll see it because you know
we're a country of many different
nations all of those flags are there
you'll see them croatian flags serbian
flags greek italian you name it they're
there
interestingly a lot of people from
eastern europe who have said to me
privately that we are worried because we
have seen this before uh that's
certainly the story of my my ancestors
my grandma fled former communist
yugoslavia because i think effectively
she was telling
her son my father things at the dinner
table that he was repeating in front of
his school teachers and that started
getting a bit a bit hot so people from
the balkans people from eastern europe
are particularly susceptible we have
large communities here in this country
and they are assembling at these freedom
rallies for the purposes of
pushing
this message which is we can't be
unaware of what's happening here even if
it looks okay as we keep saying glancing
out the window
the devil is always in the detail the
detail is not being told by the media at
the moment
but we have to keep talking about it
because the only way out is strong
political leadership
making sure that people reinforce the
base of politics for the right reasons
we we have a
growing swamp in this country as well we
i keep saying that we need to drain the
billabong in this country of the
bureaucracy
but it's true everywhere we have a
growing political class that are just
not
not paying attention or don't want to
hear it at the moment and that is going
to be a massive challenge
so uh in closing here you raise a number
of interesting points one i will say i
have uh two friends in the process of
fleeing australia one of them has just
fled with their family sold all of their
possessions gotten all of their family
members and i believe their pets out and
has actually returned to their homeland
of serbia where they describe a much
freer society
so i find that
fascinating and strangely heartening
but nonetheless i think we do also have
to recognize the international dimension
of what is taking place
the freedom rallies that you have
the fact that they are not being covered
by your media is inexplicable because
even if it was tin foil hat conspiracies
it's not
it's not unnewsworthy you have thousands
of people gathering resisting
governmental mandates that should be
covered by any
proper news organization and the fact
that it isn't suggests that somebody
doesn't want people to realize how much
resistance there is which we also see
here
now americans have been
somewhat absent from the protests that
have erupted around the world that is
going to change on january 23rd when
americans gather to march on washington
against the mandates so i think it is
overdue that americans joined this
international protest movement
and um hopefully it will uh broaden the
dawning of consciousness that many of us
have seen glimmers of
yeah look i hope so too and i and i and
i think you know as you say the fact
that we have to dig to find
you know genuine news on these freedom
movements there we have a number of
independent media sources in this
country that are doing a great job
against the tide i have to say um but
unfortunately just just not enough and
that's why it's such a privilege to come
on your show and talk about it on on the
international stage because you know
that that independent media in the
united states is is much more developed
i think and mature and it's become a
very effective way i mean we see that
with with the joe rogan show i mean i
think i think what joe did was heroic to
take two people that had been largely
marginalized in peter mcculloch and
robert malone and give them um a
mainstream platform in order to talk
about issues in and i listened to both
of them i must say a very judicious very
sensible way
without barracking without you know
putting too much spice into it i think
absent somebody like that and people
like yourself who are talking about this
in a bigger on a bigger audience scale
we don't hear about it and people need
to hear what's going on and they need to
hear about it hopefully from rational
individuals that aren't um you know that
aren't trying to over egg it and i'm
certainly not trying to do that i'm i
said it before and i say it again
australia is the greatest country in the
world uh in my view and
it will continue to be that way speaking
about what's happening here cannot and i
will not allow it to be seen as being
anything other than patriotic because
what i'm trying to do is remind people
of what made this country great and that
is the ability to be able to discuss
things in a free and frank manner so we
really need to continue to talk about it
i want to thank you for the opportunity
well thank you i will say
all of that resonates with me um
we have seen a uh a gathering of voices
all of them
patriots from across the political
spectrum recognizing the jeopardy to our
nations and standing up and as
horrifying as the picture outside has
become it is very heartening to see all
of those good people join together uh in
protest so
thank you very much for
joining us i wish you the best of luck
and hopefully your prediction of an end
to this comes sooner rather than later
and we can have a follow-up conversation
about what it all means i'd love to do
that i'd love to have a
follow-up and suggest that we've uh
we've come to the end of it at some
stage soon let's hope it's sooner rather
than later may it be in 2022
i'm in all right happy new year to you
thank you thanks brit